it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
it's hollywood babylon
it's time with your hosts kevin smith
and ralph garvin
[Music]
hey kids
i got caught watching the show already i
was already watching the show can you
believe it
i can
my bad i'm still watching it now i've
just pulled it up
it's been too long that's why it's been
so well i'm i'm a fan of this show as
well ralph so i don't i'm just not on it
i also want to watch it but i got it
not only the hair club president you're
also a member speaking of hair club
look at this good look i like the
implants let's uh start this properly
ladies and gentlemen it is right now
there's 666 people watching man in a
minute
a
minute
um it is monday night in hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] on i'm kevin smith
i'm ralph garman hey
what night says party like a monday
night in hollywood you ain't kidding
look at this i'm wearing me on my teats
you and me
um it is and [ __ ] bro don't undersell
mondays in hollywood a monday in
hollywood is like a thursday in
connecticut
that's a good point thank you
i'm not quite sure what that means it's
been a red-hot minute kids
since we've seen y'all since we've been
babbling the [ __ ] on
um i went off and made a movie what
i'm sure i would have heard of that if
that was happening kept it on the down
low just like my heart attack didn't
want anybody to know about it right it's
so secretive well
you know
they call me the j.j abrams of the
independent film world like i'm a
mystery box you are you're a conundrum
wrapped in a riddle
surrounded by a pita pocket yeah
something like that but um so we went
off and made a movie so
right before we started the show ralph
and i were going like we got to figure
out
when to do a live show and where more
importantly where because from what i
understand
you know more than i our former home the
hollywood improv
right there on melrose the store collie
would improv um who put us up on the
wall yes
because at one point we we saved the
hollywood improv according to
rita i don't know about saved but we
certainly helped him more than heard him
but what i'm hearing ralph or via
twitter from folks who are
uh garmi members uh folks who follow
ralph and the ralph report word on the
street huggy bear yeah word on the
street from the ralph report where i get
all my breaking [ __ ] entertainment
news good man go to ralph report.com uh
is that
we are no longer welcome at the improv
and not in we but podcasters are ilk
not exactly that
but we're no longer welcome to play the
primo
slots on the primo knights
so you know how you and i would
sometimes take over the place on a
friday or saturday night and uh pack the
place might i add
um now they're they're holding sometimes
it was it was friday or saturday night
for
[ __ ] years and years and years and
yes
sold out shows for years and years and
years yes and i don't want this to be a
bashing of the improv because they're
lovely people and they were good to us
we were good to them and i'm i'm
friendly with everybody there and i
don't want people to turn on the improv
but they have decided to embrace their
roots as a classic stand-up comedy club
and they
no longer want to have not just us it's
not personal but no podcast because they
had pod save america which is a big
political podcast that was you know
also homed there at the improv and uh
they don't they don't want any podcast
any longer taking up their prime real
estate in terms of their thoughts
what's that all about
well from what i understand
is they would have sometimes high
profile comedians and this is common in
the stand-up business that would roll in
on a friday and saturday night and say
let me let me get up and try some new
material in between some folks who were
working tonight and you know i just want
to jump up there and that's that brings
a club cachet you know if uh you know if
i don't know who you know not a seinfeld
or a jay leno but sometimes dave spell
the dave spell comes in and says exactly
right and they say oh you can't because
it's not one of those nights we've got a
show going on a podcast show and they
don't you know you can't just jump up
there and do a set in the middle of
their show and so they were turning away
comics that they would like to develop
relationships with and so they decided
to keep those slots strictly stand up
we were offered
a five o'clock show
on a saturday
which made me think of like the the
dinner special at denny's
we are we're the golden corral of
podcasts now
like
you guys
you're a five o'clock show
you're like at like an old age home
where they would go out to have the
early dinner at some diner nearby i felt
like they were saying to us no we'll
give you a five o'clock show people can
roll it and have a snack and watch your
podcast it's important you guys get on
stage while it's still light out
because your audience they need to use
their little rascals to get back to the
van to go back to the home
um i felt old when
i was writing a thing with my kid ralph
um
and in this thing that i'm writing with
my kid which by the way isn't like you
know oh we got a hobby we got hired to
write a thing
together they haven't announced what it
is yet and one day i will but
you know point is i'm writing with my
child this kid mind you
for those who
come in late
came out of my balls at one point in
this heck you say yeah i mean yeah like
she's legit
flesh of my flesh
none of my nuts so
me and the kid are writing a thing in
which there are adult characters my age
and there are 20 something characters
um closer to her age harley's 22.
so
we're writing this thing and i'm like
you know i'm i'm on a good roll here i
think i'm going to take a crack
at the scene
with the 20-something kids because
you're hip
clerks bro sure you know
more you're the voice of a generation
no so i thought so
right the scene i felt like wait um you
know i can
i feel pretty good about this dialogue
send it off to the kid
kid
this is the kid's response dad
no 20-somethings talk like this and i
was like well i mean
well
so like
they'll talk the way i tell them to talk
like
you know diablo cody made a bunch of
kids talk in a way nobody talks and she
won an oscar so
if you're writing you'll get to dictate
the tone never mind
never mind like you know it should sound
a certain way like you get to you get to
decide how it should you know i felt
like where to put yourself first kevin i
felt like i felt like principal skinner
where i'm like am i wrong
no
it's the children who are am i out of
touch no it's the children who are wrong
one of the characters go was
she goes that no 20 something's talked
like this i was like kiddo
you don't get it like i like made my
bones
as the guy who wrote 20 something
dialogue i'm the king of 20-something
dialogue and she was like in the 90s dad
you're 50.
and i was like i'm 51. and she's like
you
oh i got tagged am i bleeding oh bro it
hurt it hurt
it hurt to have my kid like tell me that
like i'm not
the words i'm putting in the mouths of
20 something characters
sound like a dad writing dialogue data
log if you will
it cleaved my heart and twain
but i accept my limitations although i
still
maintain like
you know
you can make them sound any way you want
so long as you make it work
and you know they don't depends on who
your audience is i guess
yeah i'm supposing 20 something audience
would like to have those characters
resonate with them
as opposed to me saying yes that's
exactly what 20 year olds would sound
like and you're steve buscemi and the
meme like hello fellow teenagers i i
honestly felt like that she made me feel
so old bro i was like oh my god who am i
kidding i was like the critics are right
i'm a [ __ ] joke did you have you i've
been watching the new snl this season i
have seen some of it yes so have you
seen this dude i don't know how to say
his name he's got three names one of
those cats with three names i know who
you're talking about yeah he's playing
trump yes number one brilliant but well
i just i fell in love with him on
twitter because he would do just walking
talks doing that impression without
makeup or anything just doing it i was
like oh my god the guy has the the brain
processes of what's going on if you do
this
it's [ __ ] uncanny how
it's more of the process than it is even
the voice because he he takes that crazy
circuitous
logic thing you know it's not like uh
like a gross caricature
um it's actually well thought out where
you're like my god that kind of is the
way
he speaks regardless that dude this week
they were doing a sketch that was uh
like uh the advertising awards the
pepsi's they called them audacity and
advertising
and it was hosted by
jake from state farm and flow from
progressive
but they looked at these ads you know
that would like
pairing weird companies with weird ads
and they were like the first is a
touching ad between a father and a son
and it was uh
uh what's his name
kyle mooney as the as the son and that
new guy what's his name on
austin something something yes a new guy
as his dad and he's like the idea is
he's telling the kid he's like
you know so
we never wan i never wanted to come out
while you know you kids were little but
now that mom's passed like
you know i i feel better about it coming
out
and um
kyle is just like wow he's like
i miss mom dad and he goes
so do i and then all of a sudden he goes
i wasted my life in the cut too
it was like facebook portals or
something like that
like a connection but the i wasted my
life
[ __ ] had me die it's one thing to do
a really good trump's another thing he
did like the sports announcer guy was
dead on but like
the [ __ ] delivery the woe in this
dude's voice in the sketch of like
i've been i've been playing straight my
whole life and i wish i'd been oh it was
[ __ ] fantastic
that guy's great he's like a phil
hartman i'll tell you something he came
out of the shoot on episode one austin
johnson that's his name yes that's it he
came out of the shoot on episode one of
his first time on stage like he had been
on snl for three seasons i was blown
away by his composure and his poise and
his
like just he stuck the landing it was
pretty impressive the there's three new
kids this year he's been wonderful um
this dude uh is his name
aristotle
aristotle yeah did you see his sketch
where he was the guy who was like uh
the improvisational singer yes
that was brilliant
um he was so [ __ ] good and then the
new girl was her name uh
um
she just did the the
the uh
weekend update bit where she just like
ranked on colin oh yeah he's been in a
couple sketches but yeah it was real
breakthrough for her she was funny
it's good man yeah of course
good to see new blood
uh jram and chad is going what blows my
mind is people still watch snl
i don't watch it in real time but like
in a world where i look at a zillion
things on youtube like why wouldn't i
look at that particularly that's the
best way to do it man you can go through
sketches real fast skip the music music
was always my least
fa like music not even least favorite
part like i never watched the live music
performances unless it was run dmc or
talking heads you know i never tuned in
for that i tuned in
[ __ ] chuckle and [ __ ] i i
was my hot take ralph in case anyone was
like why'd you tune into snl i'm like i
tuned in for the laughs
you watched the comedy show for comedy
that's that's the kind of rebel i am
that's right inside the box man that's
why my kid can't deal with me man this
is why we can't work together man
because your takes are just too hot
too uh by the way the folks who were
saying oh you guys are doing your show
again together i thought there was some
beef or something you guys were like
fighting or whatever why do people just
extrapolate [ __ ] out of nothing where
does that come from i guess they found
out about our beef oh maybe
um really there's some people thought we
were beefing yeah like oh you guys you
know we've been asking for it and you
guys haven't been together and we don't
know what's going on it's like the dude
was off making a major feature film and
i have to do a show five days a week to
pay the bills we got stuff going on but
there's you know there's no beef no it's
weird whatsoever but there is also a
matter of like all right well where's
our where do we go
that's good circles back to that yeah so
i with your blessings i'm sort of
reaching out now to um
competing comedy clubs in the los
angeles area hoping to find something
that that works for us and as always
there's a little bit of degree of
difficulty because we do like to play
video clips and audio clips and our show
is sort of multimedia and not every club
can
easily uh adapt to that so um i'm trying
to do the best i can but the one in the
valley that's on like um
lankersham or something like that the
the ho ho hut or whatever
yeah yeah how big is that place and not
big enough for us
what i'd like to do is maybe get it
listen to this ladies and gentlemen the
balls on this guy are as big as you hear
about well you know if we're going for a
club at like the improv that's at 250
i'd like to maintain at least
that size
no the improv is 200
really yeah that's all
and also 200 was easy mark to hit
whenever we had like [ __ ] morning
radio to use it's an uphill battle to
fill ah people will will they'll flock
to us once we reunite and we we announce
that we're
yeah for the first show absolutely but
then we were like we'll see you next
week they're going to be like oh wait
what
again right then we're out then we're
going to retire we're going to take our
10 years and we're going to get our gold
watch and we're going to sit the [ __ ]
down no way man we got i'm sure there's
a
how big is that ho ho hut
is that really its name the whole no
it's got something ho ho or something ho
ho club or some [ __ ] thing which i
don't think i can even perform there if
that's
part of their name yes you're you're a
club snob that's who you are no but um
what the [ __ ] placing jurors in the
jersey in uh burbank
oh uh the ice house no that's in
pasadena oh my bad um
oh [ __ ] i did a i did a ralph report
live there and it was great bam um
what about the ice house oh there's
flappers
flappers
big room at least as big as the improv
they loved having us there i'm gonna
we're we're talking to them and trying
to see if we can work something out so
my god let me ask you what's your do you
want to do something like pre-new years
like at the end of this year or do you
want to wait to beginning of next or
what's your game to do i'm game whenever
i i i but i know you're you know you're
still in post and you're still editing
and putting things together and
everything i don't know shit's here i
know i'm going back east for like the
weekend of
december 4th and 5th but other than that
i'm i'm back here in town until the end
don't forget december 7th you have a
thing to shoot
the
this is the first i'm hearing of this i
do well then you know then you can't
forget it now that you've been told they
haven't [ __ ] reached out to you yet
no sir
december 7th in uh pasadena no glenda no
jc banff man
glendale or pasadena i think it's
glendale
uh i'm supposedly working on that day
yeah
take you all with 10 minutes good to
know all right um it's uh
i'll talk to my people i'll see if i can
swing it
uh
we could always come to you
it's that convenient um these are the
pickups for the folks that we you know
you know we weren't like come all the
way to new jersey to say one thing
we the way it's constructed is
we were able to do
a whole you know [ __ ] run of pickups
out here with
our famous friends who could not join us
ralph was going to come out to jersey at
one point but our date switched and
jumped around and like he said he's got
the show
five days a week so he was like wait i
was close because i was in philly but it
was for the funeral for my mom and dad
by the way how did that go
it was great we had a blast it was a lot
of fun good times
part a never imagined losing my parents
would lead to such a wonderful night but
my god was nuts that cemetery went off
did you scatter ashes or you put them in
the ground or no my uh my family has a
plot in a in a cemetery in philadelphia
and the plan was always for my parents
to be interred there
when they both passed so we held on to
mom's ashes for years and then when my
dad went we had him cremated and then we
took their urns back to philadelphia and
put him in the in the family plot that's
what they wanted so that was that trip
but it was within you know you guys were
shooting at the time but we just
couldn't work out the
the plan welcome to burial babylon
ladies and gentlemen
your hosts old and older let's talk dead
parents hey call us now if you will 1
800 babel tell us your stories about
burying your parents
what's uh how goes the ralph report my
friend plug away
spectacular the garmi is just well i
mean the best bunch of uh
people you can ask for and
they show up in a big bad way you know
every week now we pick a new charity and
we raise money for charity um it varies
from week to week but
it's been
i know it sounds so [ __ ] corny but
it's just it chokes me up every time
because these people keep showing up we
have got a member one of our own family
a garment member who's currently dealing
with cancer who has a seven-year-old son
and he's he doesn't know how much his
insurance will cover and how much
of a christmas this kid will have and
they had a gofundme page and they were
asking for twenty five hundred dollars
to cover any out of pocket medical
expenses and to give something a little
extra for the kid for christmas at his
seven year old
and so we started talking about it on
the show and
we've now raised over 12 000
for this family
and
these these are those people they're
just and it stems from
this i mean it comes from the folks who
who first found me through you through
babylon but also some folks who knew me
from the radio show but it's just
incredible how
kind and loving but also fun and funny
these people are so it's been it's just
been a great you know we're going into
it's gonna be four years in a couple
months that i've been doing how long
you've been doing it almost four years
and it's five days a week and it's it's
a lot of work but it's it's just been
awesome and so yeah it's going great and
this week on thursday i'll be talking to
steve franks i don't know if you know
steve or not but he's the creator of a
show called psych
from uh usa and america big fan of that
show i'm a big fan of psych and they're
doing their they're doing tv movies now
as a as
follow-ups to that show so he'll be a
guest and we've got a good week coming
up but
you know it's a lot of work and it's
still a one-man operation eddie pence is
my guy who sits uh with me here on the
show and works with me but um
it's it's it's great i'm just having a
blast but it you know again with you
working in the movies and me doing this
it's not as easy for us to hook up for
babel as it used to be but
covet also played a role in that it's
not it's not all our decision
i got a bunch of folks when i posted
today like hey we're going to do babylon
like michael c and chad is like oh my
god i'm completely out of the loop
is this the first babylon in forever
it's the first babylon in in like a red
hot minute because i was off making a
movie but prior to this we have been
doing hollywood babylon the caped
commentaries as yeah like weekly yeah
weekly as we continue to roll through
uh batman the batman show but this is
the first like on camera we've done
in in a minute and um a nice way to dip
our toe back in the pool before we start
taking it on the road i've been out in
the world
like i went out last week uh touring
with uh
this motion picture clerk which comes
out
on november 23rd is documentary about my
life so
we i went with malcolm to
austin to the paramount theater
i went to jersey to smod castle showed
it there twice went to st louis to the
pageant chicago to the music box theater
then i went up to toronto the queen
elizabeth and then i went over to
vancouver to the rio
so i was in rooms with hundreds of
people again um some of them [ __ ]
sold out
some places people are still like you
know i don't know if i want to go out
yet other places people like happy to go
out all the venues were like you had to
be vaccinated to get in and stuff so i
felt safe as a kitten uh plus i've been
vaccinated and i got my boosters so i'm
really that worried i'm not trying to
get it and i believe i could get it but
you know i stand on stage pretty damn
far from the [ __ ] crowd and stuff
right so it was thrilling my point being
to get back into a room
with living people reacting to you in
the moment in that space like
it's just i i i have been enjoying
interacting with the fans
like during the quarantine we've been
doing the movies pop-up so i was still
able to go to places and interact with
fans but oh my lord being able like to
jump on stage and
rock the mic [ __ ] you know q and a
[ __ ]
throw a [ __ ]
set up and then a well-placed punch line
and have the room like like oh it's just
i missed it so [ __ ] much
so i got greedy for it the sooner we
could do a live babylon here in town the
better yeah i'm i'm jealous i'm looking
forward to it i'm doing a show in
december
um on a sunday at the improv of all
places that a buddy of mine is putting
together that is a christmas um music
and comedy show
all rat pack themed and i will be
hosting as the ghost of frank sinatra
and uh
um i can't wait to get on stage in front
of an audience again and feel that
fight or flight
vibe of okay if this is going to land
and we're going to laugh here we're
going to die i mean i just think
didn't you get the johnson and johnson
vaccine i did get the j yes so cut to
old-timey comic ralph garmin dies after
catching coven at the improv i'm
boostered i boosted up
um that sounds fun [ __ ] man and you get
to act too so it's not just like i'm
going to be funny on stage you actually
get to perform on stage yeah well yes
that's it's
it's an impression so i've got a little
experience doing that in front of
people's faces some actors have won
oscars for impressions i i i've heard
tale of that sort of thing but i don't
know if that's me or not um
we are in hollywood and we are babbling
on but i guess people want us to do
hollywood babylon i saw a few people
bitching and chat about like do your
[ __ ] backstage [ __ ] on your own time
i forgot the show cost so much money to
them
you know we should do exactly what the
audience wants but when you announced
this i saw so many about [ __ ] times i
was like
what what have we done to people to make
them so agitated about a free show
you made them love you and then you took
it all away man well talk to the virus
man
you were you're [ __ ] um
you were like ted lasso and they're all
like ned
yeah right ned nate they're all like
[ __ ] like you pump me up and then you
turn your back on me turn me down
how awesome is that ted lasso show
uh
may
sing i don't know if you saw my
halloween costume or not but i i i went
full ted lasso that was my halloween
costume this year get out of here yeah
i was in the tracksuit and the visor and
the uh i'll tell you man ray-bans and
the mustache that's how good that show
is because that's a trekly little show
in many ways right very much about
kindness very much had a has a
sweetheart running through it and other
than you weeping at like [ __ ] um
tale as old as time
even friends then somebody bends and
offers up their ass that's like that
makes you emotional to hear that a ted
lasso works on on you
i if i was the people who made ted lasso
if i was apple tv i'd put that on the
[ __ ] poster
even ralph garmin finds it touching even
his black heart was moved does it make
you cry have you cried watching it i
have yes
uh the when the the the funeral episode
did you watch season two have you
watched season two yeah i've re-watched
it and oh yeah yeah the the funeral
episode with rebecca's dad and lasso
talking about his dad and stuff he had
that oh that was cutting in that was
[ __ ] brilliant genius
by the way
tale as old as time doesn't make me cry
anymore so let that go
now i'm into because you've you ruined
it because you just you bludgeoned me
with it the point where i'm numb now i
can't feel anything anymore thanks to
you
but now i'm into coco's uh remember me
from from the uh disney movie coco oh
remember me
those pixar movies dare you not to
[ __ ] end your own life out of [ __ ]
sadness oh my god and he's singing to
his little daughter in the afterlife and
oh for [ __ ] sake yeah that whole thing
uh you know that's a wonderful movie but
i think if you're in
our line of work that movie hit harder
because you know it's all about like god
i hope [ __ ] this was off or something
you're hoping they remember you today
right let alone [ __ ] like after
you've died or something i remember
watching that movie
and crying alongside my kid before
completely different [ __ ] reasons
that she was crying mine were more
selfish where i'm like they're gonna
forget me i know it
that's why you gave her the the rights
to sell all the kevin smith merch after
you're gone now i'm just selling my boy
[ __ ] from [ __ ] like i wasted my life
that made me laugh so hard dude i
rewound that [ __ ] ten times in the
middle of the night that reminds me of
the
or is this funny and it was legit funny
that reminds me of the paraplegic stuck
on the it's a what it's a it's a small
world ride on
um all right
all right people complaining enough of
our talking our friendship they want us
to get the [ __ ] bits should we do
that now they want some yeah they want
bits so like be [ __ ] funny that's
what we pay you for dance monkey on the
free show
yes sir
all right let's talk about dead people
in show business shall we
and now another edition of
they will be missed yeah oh my god
you're gonna start the show with the
deaths forever yeah i am yeah i like a
challenge
winter the dolphin is dead
winter the dolphin
nothing no no recognition
well i just hope that she lived her
poipous
and we're back
winter the dolphin inspired dolphin tale
and its sequel dolphin tale 2 the story
of a dolphin who lost her tail in a crab
trap line
and had to have a prosthetic tail and
learn how to swim again
this is a
dance of
your new story
and she
and she was an inspiration not only to
other dolphins kevin who loved that film
i assume
but folks who had prosthetic limbs of
their own who took inspiration from her
story
look i have a small dick and i was
inspired by the [ __ ] story right
because you wear prosthetic [ __ ] quite
often
it's in my head it's not real but in my
head i have to mount up before i mount
up if you will have you looked into the
baldo
what is the ball though the baldo is a a
brand new
uh
revelation in sex toys
it's a sex toy that is dildo shaped
but you insert your testicles into the
dildo
and then you use spacers to stretch your
scrotum and enlarge your scrotum to fill
it with uh you know to make it turgid
and then you insert that into your
partner instead of your penis
why
well not only for her pleasure but the
creators of the baldo claim that the
sensitivity of the skin on the scrotum
can actually lead a man to have a
ballgasm
a ballgasm that's what they call it yes
and i i've i've purchased one i've i own
one i just haven't had a chance to try
it out yet so
a bargasm sounds so [ __ ] threatening
really slip that [ __ ] ballgasm in her
mouth right now
put it in your mouth like oh please
don't make me do this
not ball gag
ballgasm it's a very different thing
orgasm is
is a really it's a dark
instantly it does it doesn't invoke good
times
it's like an orgasm but with your balls
i'll let you know how it works out i'll
keep you posted um
uh now another edition of
they will be missed somebody else died
who
gavin o'harahee
gavin o'hara first was that the first
chuck
shut the front door look at you yes
that's exactly who that was it was chuck
cunningham the eldest brother of the
cunningham family
that's the oldest internet joke in the
world even before there was an internet
even as far back as the 70s we were all
talking about
whatever happened to chuck man he just
went upstairs and never came back
downstairs and they stopped talking
about him what the [ __ ] that was a meme
you're right before there were memes we
talked about there was a time before
continuity
tv shows didn't have [ __ ] continuity
sitcoms they just
they were just half hours and you know
loosely
strung together over a year or whatever
but like
the idea of
like going hey man whatever happened to
chuck and how come you guys stopped
talking about him like they were like
who gives a [ __ ] moving forward
literally that is the the diagnosis of
what 70s television was which was it's
just a distraction nobody's supposed to
take it too seriously
a character can come a character can go
it just doesn't matter just watch us for
a half an hour buy the products and then
go about your life
but he died at the age of 70 so chuck
cunningham
is gone
speaking of a gary marshall character
gary marshall as we all know created
happy days so chuck sprang forth from
the pen of the great gary marshall yes
well as laverne and shirley mork and
mindy and
so forth and so on
just recently
it was felix unger day
which i guess two days ago uh because it
was november 13th and if you ever watch
the
yard couple the show began with you know
the opening credit sequence the
voiceover going like on november 13th
felix unger's wife threw him out or
whatever the [ __ ] and she requested that
he never returned
um deep down he knew she was right
uh but that that
you know
threw me down the rabbit hole
of like oh i'm gonna go watch
the opening credits to [ __ ] the odd
couple
on youtube even though i hated the odd
couple when i was a child what i did i
hated it hated it
couldn't i love that show
when i grew up i understood it and liked
it a lot but as a kid
it just meant that like all the kid
programming was over no more cartoons
because these old men are gonna [ __ ]
throw spaghetti at the wall [ __ ] that
so i had a resent a resentment to them
meanwhile i liked the oddball couple
which was a cartoon version with a very
fastidious cat and an oh fleabag yes yes
well done
um
in watching the opening credits
you know if you're well studied in in
this [ __ ]
we all know that neil simon created the
odd couple right it was a movie starring
jack lemmon walter matthau was a
broadway play before it was a movie
before that it was broadway play
gary marshall
developed the odd couple for television
true a show that had maybe what 10 years
of episodes yes
before
[ __ ] happy days bro
yes
like this dude was a giant like so
[ __ ] prolific if he was living and
working today
gary marshall would be like shonda
rhimes plus ryan murphy plus
[ __ ]
times dick wolf yeah yes this dude
[ __ ] worked man like because when you
think about how long
all those shows went on
like this dude figured out a [ __ ]
form and yes like some of the formulas
were borrowed from
overseas right like um
was he one of those guys no that was
norman lear that was
right so gary marshall was like well
gary marshall stole he bit from george
lucas
for happy days because
happy days came before
american graffiti came out the [ __ ] you
say it's true look at you
happy days couldn't get sold
until american graffiti came out after
the fact and was a big hit and then
suddenly they wanted a 50s program is
that right it's true he created the
pilot for
happy days
before american graffiti
it didn't fly
he sold it to abc to to and they've
turned it into an episode of love
american style to burn off the pilot and
then afterwards american graffiti was
released and then the appetite for 50
shows became so enormous he was able to
recycle that idea and sell it again to
abc all right so that was in the 70s yes
so in the 70s they were into the 50s
which means in the 80s they were into
the 60s which means in the 90s
they were into the 70s which means in
the oughts they were into the
80s which means they should be into the
90s right about now right this should be
your time right yeah [ __ ] it should be
ascended man
this should be the moment that i get my
comeback and [ __ ] like [ __ ] once a
lunar whatever the [ __ ]
forget clerks three clerks the sitcom
that's where the money is
oh
if only it's so crazy i never like got
into it for the loot i wonder if gary
will change that attitude i can't i'm
too old you can't [ __ ] old dog new
tricks licking balls something like that
do you think gary marshall was in it for
the money
yes he always wanted to make
strictly commercial
across the board populist entertainment
he never had any desires to be artistic
in any way if you talk to the cast of
pretty woman
which again you know you talk about this
guy being a tv
monster then he went on to direct and
and you know shepherd one of the biggest
romantic comedies
you know of of the era
they always said
they always said he was just about
just
just make the people laugh that's all i
want i don't want you to do work so much
work where everybody's looking for
artistic stuff i just want the laughs
just get laughs from people then we'll
be happy
it's like he's back
thank you
wow man you're the austin james johnson
gordon of this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
you just [ __ ]
channeled
the great gm himself
um i met him once late in his life we
talked about it on babylon i think when
he passed yeah um and i got to tell him
like
hey man not for i told his his sister
because she came to the house penny and
[ __ ]
did uh
well it sounded like it was going to be
juicy right she [ __ ] came to the
house in the house that she
laverned my shirley but she came to the
house and did a a series of podcasts
with me and she was wonderful
um but i blew her up about like look i
loved her work but i was like your
brother made one of my favorite movies
of all time
nothing in common yeah that's great
easton and tom hanks like one of tom
hanks's
best performances of all time so i got
to tell him that years later i met him
and i was like oh my god i wish i had
put that guy on a podcast i wish i'd can
you imagine the stories oh
[ __ ]
i would have been sitting there being
like hey man thank god for american
graffiti you george lucas bite and son
of a [ __ ] and he would have been like
here give me the [ __ ] i was going to do
an impression but there's gary marshall
right tell your story is that first
before that before lucas
there were there was me i was the guy
who wanted 50s before nobody wanted 50s
and then they came to me after the lucas
and they said yes
give me your 50s and i'll give you a
check and that's what i cared about was
the check at the time see kids what you
forgot was hollywood babylon
is all about talking about our dead
parents and doing impressions
of octogenarians
creatives who just they're not even
around anymore but if you grew up in the
70s all that [ __ ] was gold
i distinctly heard you say wayne newton
schmuck
you remember his turn and lost in
america with albert brooks oh he's
fantastic
in america [ __ ]
santy claus isn't real
no
santy claus is christmas las vegas
gambling las vegas gambling they go
together
the best
how down are you down how down is she
down
all right you seem like a nice kid rooms
chomped meals
after they lost the nest egg yes
you don't get to say you messed up
bird lives at a round stick and you have
things in bacon for breakfast
um
if we give you back your money then we
have to give everybody back their money
all right now i gotta want to let's go
go watch gary marshall hey we got some
uh headlines you want to talk to us
about some show business [ __ ] yeah man
that's what i came for
[Music]
somebody wrote on twitter yes finally
mike fellatio again i was like that
probably won't happen but you made it
happen god bless you
hey are you uh relieved our long
national nightmare is over and britney
spears is finally free of her
conservatorship because good for her man
good for her because here come the dishy
details man she's making making noises
about like they're all gonna pay
they're all gonna pay and i'm here for
it man she's got the receipts bro
she's got over a decade and [ __ ]
imprisoned by her own family she's
already making noises about like that
[ __ ] sister of mine so i can't wait
now she's gonna be unleashed she's gonna
tell us everything why does everybody
care so much i can't wrap my head around
it i hadn't honestly really you know i
was she was after my
time she was like the next
decade the author me too
but um but of course i'm well aware
versus a cultural [ __ ] phenomenon but
of course i didn't know anything about
the you know i remember when she shaved
her head i didn't know
the [ __ ] they used that to like trap
her for
over a decade and like told her like you
can't have a baby even if you want to
like all of it was
mind-numbing and suddenly you were able
to watch like two different
documentaries about the subject and you
were a britney spears [ __ ] expert if
not a fan you can't help but walk away
going like oh [ __ ]
you know i feel bad for this kid who i
never thought about in my entire [ __ ]
life but like how can you be this
[ __ ] famous and still be
a victim still be victimized and that's
what it was yeah like [ __ ] so
even though i got no skin in the game
it is kind of [ __ ] fascinating and
i do like the fact that she's been out
there like not being like
you know well it all worked out so i'm
keeping my mouth shut like i think she's
gonna start like just burning it all
down and i'm
i'm here for it man i will be intrigued
to find out as we dig deeper what really
went on because
i've been
involved in people in my life who have
um
if not mental illness but have issues
and they often talk like she has talked
in the past which is everybody's against
me and they won't let me do this and
they won't let me do that and they're
and those
and i don't doubt her position at all in
terms of feeling real to her but those
aren't always necessarily the facts so i
think it'll be interesting to watch
things flesh out one way or the other
but the bottom line for me the
fascination for me was
the
amazing
response by the american public there
was dancing in the streets there was
partying in the streets when her
conservatorship was ended
and it's hard to get
people show up for a a climate
crisis uh uh protest but when it comes
to this stuff hey
run her for [ __ ] president oh yes
finally let's just go down in a you know
just a
bag of flames why not why well how could
it be any worse you're right you know
she's she's uh she seems to be
a pretty smart lady very big splash
um i'm happy for her man good for her
everybody should
[ __ ] be the captain of their own
destinies particularly when they're
she's a grown-ass woman man that's true
and she's got [ __ ] kids and like they
use those kids controller the whole
thing's [ __ ] sad and sick but
what you're not taking into
consideration
raphael is that this girl has
not she's not a girl not yet a woman
but she has grown up
with the american public you know first
it was the mickey mouse club
then it was her own
shindig man her own agency as we thought
she is us
yeah or or she's been a part of like i
remember
i told this story recently somewhere so
i forget where it was i'll tell it again
one and only time i met
robin williams
was when we were making goodwill hunting
we were on the toronto set
and um
they were shooting uh
the scene in the bar
where he goes to the bartender hey uh
what's this guy he's like oh that's the
that's the una bomber like he's like hey
who's ted krasinski he's like that's a
unibomber like that scene
was there was a scene in the bar and
then he was kind of
augmenting it it was so funny because
this was pre
hardcore internet you're talking about
1997.
um 1996-97
so ben and matt were like since they
wrote the script
robin wanted to do a thing where he
referenced three people
and they were brilliant people and this
guy never heard of him but then he
referenced ted kaczynski and this guy
did hear of him yeah so he was like i
need to get there so i need a bunch of
details on the guy and i'll never forget
like those dudes not going like today
you would just open up your google app
and [ __ ] be like
let's let's go to the wiki for ted
kuczynski and you know we'll pull a
bunch of lines and stuff right literally
had to pull books there were books being
brought to the bar
that they could [ __ ] encyclopedia
type
that they could go through and be like
okay
and and pull out things so that robin
could construct the line he wanted to do
anyway that's a side story one that i
haven't actually really told before i'm
pretty impressed by that um the real
story that i wanted to tell was this
when i met him
we were going into the bar he was going
into the bar there's a bar in toronto
and a bunch of people uh from outside
the torontonians who knew there was a
movie shooting and don't forget
um ben and matt were not ben and matt at
this point right they would become ben
and matt off of this movie but they've
definitely been in some stuff matt had
just been in like a big role in courage
under fire with like meg ryan and denzel
washington
but
you know ben was coming off by you know
mall rats and chasing amy if that i
don't even know if chasing amy was out
yet when they shot yeah i know it was
definitely out so
people outside the bar are going mork
mork oh jeez now and mind you this is
robin williams like
good wall hunting of course he wins an
oscar but he's already [ __ ] pretty
damn famous this is robin williams of
hook fame at this point a [ __ ] good
morning vietnam fame a [ __ ] dead poet
society fame right maybe even patch
adams i forget where that was in the run
but like he was already a [ __ ] movie
star a bonafide
100 percent [ __ ] movie star who
hadn't been on tv in a dog's age and yet
there were people outside going morg
so you know i'm [ __ ] like i'm in my
what at that point
28 or whatever the [ __ ]
so i'm still like trying to be cool
kevin smith
and i'm like oh my god like
you must hate hearing work and he's like
no i actually like it he's going i like
it a lot he's i was going but it's mork
like it was from years ago and he's like
that's the power of television he's gone
like when you're in a movie they go to a
movie theater and they see you and so
you're another you're an entity outside
of their world
um when you're in their home
every week you are family mm-hmm oh and
so like them yelling mork
like i i was a big part of their lives
um and still to this day even though
i've done a bunch of other things
like that resonates
because you know i was and it's
something that like at the time i was
like yeah i guess so
and you know years later after i did
clerks and mall rats and those movies
still have [ __ ] resonance and not
nearly the same situation as much as he
was on [ __ ] tv and a bonafide tv hit
but
people
like any the audience i've had a lot of
them take me and take me into their
heart because of a specific time
that they watch the movie that it's tied
to you know what i'm saying like they'll
still
even i can make [ __ ] yoga hoses and
they'll be like yeah but when he made
[ __ ] that clerk's picture
always [ __ ] yoga hosers because that
was the last one that they really [ __ ]
on uh unjustly
not right or anything but just all right
i'll say tusk thank you we made that
[ __ ] tusk picture of some which by
the way you were in as well so but just
this yeah
that was in this that damn red state
movie with the non-talky [ __ ]
it's just like i like you know i
you need a series that's what it all
comes down to
is it remember remember that sitcom
pilot we tried to put together for that
uh
competition thing they were doing over
at cbs where you were the manager of the
movie theater
welcome
yeah it was so good those good times
um all right
all right well we [ __ ]
i don't know
doesn't matter though we're still
talking about headlines
this is the only headline i care about
because this is the [ __ ] hottest
showbiz story going and everyone keeps
talking about it and i don't quite
understand the the hubbub as the kids
say
are you familiar with sofia euresta
lead singer for a band called
brass against i i was not familiar with
this woman until
two in the morning the other night this
week you're now you're now you know who
she is
yeah because i saw a video
that i probably would have watched on
pornhub if they
if they put it in the right category did
you see that video did i i can't stop
seeing it
like i saw it all right i've got it on a
loop twice
um it is uh yeah it's
well i mean here
for those who don't are unfamiliar
um
normally on babylon we'd run a clip and
[ __ ] but yeah i'm just watching against
it anytime i try to run a clip on
youtube even if it's a [ __ ] trailer
for something i've done
they pull our show off the air or
something i get i'm [ __ ] noticed from
youtube we can paint a picture with
words it's fine and also you could just
google what is it you're just google
your sofia uristo or brass against or
daytona and any combination of those or
a guy being on stage
and he's laying down and she like squats
over him pulls her pants not all the way
down but down enough he drops trowel
yeah
uh but tastefully so i would say i do
too and that's the last tasteful thing
that happens because then right after
that
sprays this [ __ ] well in all in
you know in her defense she had been
saying on stage for a while that she had
to pee really badly
and she couldn't get off stage to do it
so we might as well make it part of the
show and she brought an eager willing
young man up on stage who had a gopro
strapped to his head apparently
that's what she said she calls the match
goes i want the guy with the camera
strapped to his head apparently he was
wearing a gopro
videoing the the concert i assume
brought him up on stage laid him down
and then she proceeded to uh give him
the
most golden of showers
i mean
i look
i wish i was at that show
right that's what i keep saying i'm
really not a big fan of live music it's
too loud once again this is the old man
show old and older ladies and gentlemen
statler and waldorf
and i you know it's been years since
i've enjoyed live music because
you know you never hear the lyrics all
you hear is the instruments and stuff
um but
i would [ __ ] i'd go for some live
music if somebody was like oh no stick
around four or five songs in
you're gonna see some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you're gonna be that's rock and roll
in one way when i looked at that clip i
was like
you know look i'm a 51 year old man
admittedly and we live in an age where
covid and germs have you know [ __ ]
taken a lot of people out and stuff and
i'm trying to be a responsible person
but
you know i was like isn't that what rock
and roll is like [ __ ] pushing it to
the edge and
i'm with you pal i was all i was all
over that i'm gonna follow this band
forever unfortunately they're only
touring in europe right now but i'm did
you say i'm going to follow this band
forever i'm going to be like one of
those guys and who follow fish in a van
selling falafel in the parking lot
this is going to be my new thing i'm
just going to follow around brad
why don't you and ralph do babel anymore
are you fighting i'm like no you're
[ __ ] fighting for his attention
because he won't take it away from
urinating urista he's following him on
tour
he's literally
he's in a van following brass against
with a gopro stapled to his forehead
hoping one night she'll call him out of
the crowd problem is you will never
get that show again
well they've already said they apologize
and said this isn't us as a band i would
beg to differ and say well apparently it
is
and she's apologized she said she even
cleaned up the stage afterwards i think
you're missing the point of the act but
god bless yeah all of it was just like
as it was going on i was like i mean i'm
not gonna say it was flat out gigi allen
but there were
elements an error of gigi allen to it
and as much as iggy pop and all those
guys it was definitely a punk move
and it helps that she's a she's a lovely
uh fit
uh lesbian i think which adds to the
whole uh
the
the the mystique of the whole event is
just magical i've seen clips where they
uh put a little blurry patch ah
don't spend your time on those clips
if i quickly i was like now wait a
second this is the internet there's no
way they're all blocked out and then
there's right where it's not like you
can see anything she's on a profile
angle but
it's
because i was looking to be like can't
be this guy this has got to be an act
this is like guar or some sort of [ __ ]
like there's no way it's real pissed
this is gene simmons spitting up blood
at a kiss show there's after i watched
that clip i was like there's no way
that's not real piss
you see that dude he [ __ ] like free
willies it
like does a mist and [ __ ] blows it out
yeah
reminded me my youth is he uh oh my god
is he do is there follow-up is he happy
unhappy oh happy as a clam just couldn't
couldn't be happy happy as larry is the
brit
i rethought about it now that everyone's
laughed at me i don't want it anymore no
he is he he's he's got the best souvenir
ever
from a from a show
wow yeah i mean look is there anything
or anybody you're a big enough fan of in
this world that you take a face full of
their piss
um
the fact that you're even [ __ ]
thinking about it
tells me there's about 12.
[Laughter]
i there are people i would experience
the vip
backstage experience with yes for sure
um yeah putting the p back in vip
um
look as long as that guy is happy i mean
it is weird though right like you're
doing like let's say you own that
that venue
and you're like oh i love to see the
young people get with their rocks and
rolls and they're boogie and then all of
a sudden this person squats and pisses
all over your station you're like what
the [ __ ] again i reiterate sophia
cleaned it up after the gig so
even so i'm gonna come over your house
piss all over your kitchen table but i'm
like don't worry i'm gonna clean it up
you know urine is mostly sterile
of all the bodily fluids it's probably
the safest
what about if it's coming out of a dog
is i've never really entered into that
that part of the conversation i got i
got a dog remember mad martign yeah
dog she's uh
blind
deaf
and she can't
get up at the back legs so she can move
these legs and stuff
so she's basically a piss and pooping
piece of furniture right and as a guy
who like every hour in the hour wakes up
this is love kids and some people like
you shouldn't keep a dog around that
long [ __ ] my vet was a great vet
and
he the dude
he'd be the first to tell us like kill
this [ __ ] dog man it's too late
he's like is she eating i was like every
day like a [ __ ] little pig
a big fat pig like the dog can't move
and so guess what she's like 95 pounds
he's like as long as that dog is eating
and drinking that dog does not want to
die he's like that dog will let you know
when she wants to go the moment she
stops eating and drinking
and so you know this dog is eating and
drinking us out of house and home all it
is is like poo and pee material i feed
in one side and clean up out the others
every hour in the hour i get up with her
man like because she either take us
needs a drink or [ __ ] has to take a
whiz or a [ __ ] ass to take a [ __ ]
and i don't [ __ ] about doing it because
when we were coming home from clerks 3
jennifer was like i think marty's about
to die we're gonna have to put marty
down and that was like
i was crestfallen like you know this
ain't my dog so to speak
jen was the one that brought this dog
into our lives but i've become very fond
of the [ __ ] dog and i do feel like
because we went and shot the movie
in jersey we were gone for two months
that dog
you know she didn't know like [ __ ] there
were people here but the two people that
she's so used to living with in that
room and she
constantly showered affection and
tension on her were gone and i
jen felt like when she came home that
the dog was like dying of a broken heart
and [ __ ] and then the two of us coming
back
the dog is completely [ __ ] rally that
being said
she's rallied but she's still blind
still deaf and still can't [ __ ] move
so she still remains a
pooing piecing pooling or peeing piece
of furniture but so she's punishing you
for having been gone for so long now you
will clean up my feces and my urine well
let me tell you well that's why i go
back to this
core question here
if urine is
sterile
does that mean dog urine is sterile i
don't believe so dog urine is filled
with ammonia from what i understand
not so much with uh human beings why
why don't we have ammonia in our piss ah
jeez talk to your god i don't know i
don't know how to find a problem
dogma bro
years ago as a matter of fact
i'm not sure i'm not i'm not a
specialist in the field i'm not a
urologist but to the best of my
knowledge dog urine is filled with
ammonia that's why it kills the grass
where they go and not so much uh humans
so if i go out and if i had a yard i got
a back deck because this is [ __ ] the
hollywood hills but if i had grass in my
backyard and i went and took a leak on
the grass every day in the same spot i
wouldn't burn the grass like dogs do no
you would not
how do you [ __ ] know why do you know
that i guess because you have a daily
podcast where you have to come up with
an interesting factoid i'm constantly
looking for and i have a backyard with
grass and a dog and i also pee
you go out there every morning and
you're like i'm a single man and you put
your hands on your [ __ ] back of your
head
and it's bachelor time baby sprinkler
that [ __ ] you're like good morning van
nuys
neighbors are like
that garmin guy's out there pretending
he's a [ __ ]
ring bird
yeah
look
you won't let the dog piss in the yard
oh no but look at him pissing all over
he's i heard him bragging about having
some of that ammonia free piss
i'm making my claim
yeah
no but i've also uh no i won't get into
that
oh no how do you don't [ __ ] bury that
lead you're like well i've been i've
been involved in situations with women
where that has been part of the the sex
play
and so i i'm i'm aware that that's not
an
i'm wait what don't just roll past that
what piss play like golden shower yeah
everybody's tried it
no they haven't yeah they have
uh don't say it or they don't half of
our
1300 audience just tuned out they're
like ew you hollywood piss player
um what is uh don't cost the same either
way what
what uh
ralph water sports garmin what uh when
when was that a thing
this was in my 20s i
had an experience with a girl and it
went it went differently than i expected
it wasn't warm
i've had this conversation before on the
ralph report we've talked about this but
we were engaged in
what one would call a 68 in the sense
that she was on top of my
it was a 69 and then she sat up
and i was still doing my job
and she was sitting on your face yes and
she was very excited and she was really
enjoying herself that was a long way to
go for she was sitting on your face she
was like you're like i'm trying to be a
little a little bit delicate so
technically a 68.
trying to be delicate
she was sitting on my face and she was
really enjoying herself and she started
getting more and more excited and she
said to me
rather
vocally drink me and i assumed she meant
that she was so wet from excitement that
i would have to to to drink her and
that's not what she meant at all and she
uh
she released
in my mouth on my face and that was her
thing that's what got her excited
and
it was fine
did you drink her of course
the [ __ ] i'm a gentleman
i'm a gentleman oh couldn't you just
pretend to be like
oh i'm drinking is good and then spit it
out the side and [ __ ]
there's thighs you can't you're one of
those you're one of those heat of the
moment people aren't you yes and i'm
also a method actor you know that about
me so
don't blame this on the arts don't you
bring the crap i was researching a role
little piss playing [ __ ] wow man
this is uh this is this is the [ __ ]
hottest episode of hollywood babylon in
a long time well we're back we gotta
bring it right this is the piss warmest
episode of hollywood babylon in a long
time yeah
um wow man you've once again you you're
like an onion with many layers and i've
lived a life kevin smith you really
you've lived
uh this life a lot of people
you know or just every man is born
but not every man truly lives no kid
you're the mel gibson of this [ __ ] well
maybe not him the william wallace this
[ __ ]
uh man oh man you did just sucked a
[ __ ] nectar and marrow out of this
[ __ ] good for you literally yeah [ __ ]
all right let's get to our last showbiz
story
single man pissing in his [ __ ] lawn
in his backyard
where are you now life changes kevin
it's like the end of it's like the end
of uh [ __ ] casino you got real big
glasses
you live in a one room
good fellas i'm picking up a newspaper
in the front lawn drinking tomato sauce
for gravy
i'm gonna smoke like everybody else
that's right what else you got newswise
[Music]
so different without 200 people
screaming it back at you i know we'll
get there there's more
our biggest i think we had an audience
of 1500 screaming yeah that oh god
i think you're right
wasn't even more in the uk were we doing
that bit when we did the first show at
the yeah yeah that the yeah the kazodian
how big is that place that was like six
thousand wasn't it smith apollo the
hammers apollo yeah yeah
um bieber bieber's in business with tim
hortons did you see this broke my heart
um hey man tim hortons is a canadian
company
bieber is a canadian company as much as
he doesn't cop to it that much but here
he is copping to it
would i prefer they give that money to a
true canadian legend a la eugene levy or
something like that
or an alanis morissette
yes yes do i understand what they did
i mean
maybe they're trying to sell
you know [ __ ] timbits to to an
audience that ain't buying it but i mean
who is the bieber audience at this point
i'm not denying he has one but how old
are they
i i have to assume
[Music]
20 somethings
i don't think he's attracting the the
teeny
bopper audience that he did he came up
with i have to assume there are people
who followed his career up till now
because he's certainly not generating
white hot music right now
they don't um
snoogans ladies and gentlemen snoogans
of champions california arizona
oklahoma all the uh states
anything with an a nevada that's another
one
soon michigan uh georgia canada is there
canada yeah in the next 90 days i think
we go to canada but it's fireweed anyway
back to this
um what uh has he brought to the to the
world i used to [ __ ] with tim hortons in
a big bad way i loved me some tim bits i
used to hide them so good thousand tim
bits when i worked on flash
my first or second episode of flash i
went into
tim hortons i was like give me a
thousand tim bits we brought them in we
like set them up and [ __ ] we had so many
timbits they were throwing them at each
other the cast at the end of the day
um so i've always been dare you what a
waste of tim bits oh nobody said they
were wasted ralph don't forget there are
dogs up there and dogs love bits too
good point especially the ones that fall
on the floor
so uh i've always been a fan of timmy's
as they say uh however since i've went
vegan very little opportunity
to interact with timmy's as their vegan
selection is woefully uh
underrepresented so you don't care about
the tim biebs
is that what they're calling it
yes
they didn't want to do a second draft of
that nope tim biebs i guess it makes
sense
does it but uh if you could put you can
pour all over them tim biebs is scissor
here are the flavors
created according to
lore by the biebs himself
chocolate white fudge
ew
sour cream chocolate chip
and birthday cake waffle
the [ __ ]
none of this story sounds good to me at
all this kid can't even get [ __ ]
donuts right right how hard is that
you know what to be fair tough to come
up with new donut flavors
is it i don't know bust me here [ __ ]
go come up with one
um
show me you're better than bieber
without showing me you're better than
bieber uh
really hot 20 year old urine donuts
[Laughter]
a rarefied market ralph i've had
experience i'm telling you there's a
flavor to be had there it's really tough
to communicate on a on an order board i
suppose
and just think of the poor postmates
driver has to bring that tea in tim
peace
tim peace
um wow justin bieber continues to get
wealthy you and i struggling as per
usual yeah i know
he's getting money from tim bits
i am uh i'm spending money on tim bits
but not on the ones he's making those no
flavors don't appeal to me at all and
again
none of them are vegan now
you tell me the story where he's like uh
you know biebs is bringing the first
plant-based timbit
to the table then i'm like this kid's a
national [ __ ] hero as far as i'm
concerned
you do that thought of himself first
says quick you are to change allegiances
i'm all right look i'm aligned to plant
nation my friend they saved my life
and
since you know there are very few fun
things to eat in plant nation
you know a [ __ ] timbit or two would
be nice [ __ ] got like 80 different
flavors can't have one
for the vegans and frying [ __ ] is very
vegan you know you're getting it it's
fried and it's vegan that's how they
mask the flavor
stop it i'm just saying
um
let me tell you something
i've never been more jealous of justin
bieber than hearing that
tim hortons is like invent a doughnut
for us eh
why don't you come on in and invent a
donut for us eh come on come into
timmy's and have a donut with us and
invent a donut and yet sour cream
chocolate chip was where he went so fail
you brought up flash real quick um
how did you feel about the uh the finale
of supergirl
bittersweet i mean yeah
like you know it's time to move on and
whatnot i thought you might
but um it was you know i was that was a
very lovely family up there
and um you gotta remember this is a show
that kind of like the character she
played
she went on a bit of a journey like she
didn't start life as a cw show it was a
[ __ ] cbs show that was shooting in
los angeles
and she was coming off of glee melissa
so you know after one season here in los
angeles they're like
we're moving the show to cw and it's
gonna go shoot in vancouver
and you know she wasn't like
i didn't [ __ ] sign up for that like
she went to canada for the next five
years mercifully she found true love up
there that's where she met woody and
stuff and now they're family they're
married they got kid
so uh it all works out and stuff but
like never once did she fight it or like
you know you know and some people like
she why should she she's having a job
when maybe if somebody told her at the
beginning
you
if you like this you may have to go to
canada for this job maybe she wouldn't
have gone you know what i'm saying not
that she has anything against canada but
when you're on a show like that you live
in a concrete [ __ ] block
for eight to nine months out of the year
you know like never get to go home to
your true home you get to go to your
local home at that at best and no time
really to go home on the weekends and
stuff and again it's like i'm sure some
people like don't feel bad for them
they're making a lot of money yeah but
when the ride started she wasn't told
you're going to be doing the ride in
canada
and
as number one on a show
you set the tone
so she could have went up north and been
like i don't even want to [ __ ] be
here i signed up to be on an american
[ __ ] show
and instead she was always so goddamn
lovely and meant everyone else had to be
lovely
as well um so there was such a great
family up there and
you know
i'll miss
the opportunity to go
and play with them it was an honor to be
able to jump into their world
and it's such a well-organized world
that even an idiot like me couldn't [ __ ]
up the episodes that he worked on and
i got some of my best
reviews in my career for those supergirl
episodes like even considering like the
movies i've made and stuff still a lot
of people like that stuff and melissa on
uh recently on like a look back special
um i think during the dc thunderdome or
whatever [ __ ]
fandom
she was uh she talked about like her
favorite episode was the
uh the one the one we did with the mo
you know where we where we left the
planet for the first time we talked
um
to uh
the controversially named slavers moon
um
and that involved monel and and you know
she
she fell in love she dug that dude yeah
he's charming [ __ ] he's a tough dude not
to telling you the world has missed it
maybe not missed this opportunity it's
still [ __ ] time but that dude
that is fletch that is who [ __ ]
gregory mcdonald wrote about when he
wrote the series of flesh books it
wasn't like somebody like
you know standard looking like cheby
chase or whatever he the fletch
character is [ __ ] gorgeous that's why
he gets laid like [ __ ] constantly and
he's charming and funny as [ __ ] so
that's chris wood 2t man he's charming
funny he's [ __ ] who wouldn't have sex
with this dude like luckily she locked
him down and stuff so i always thought
he would have made a great fletch um
well get to work
i don't have it
belongs to somebody else
jason zedekis was supposed to do it oh
really yeah he's he's busy with
something else right now no doubt he
should stay committed to that i should
ted lasso should be his life's work
you're darn tootin vladimir putin
beautiful beautiful show
um what else we got that's it i gotta
roll i gotta bounce
what the [ __ ] i got i got a ralph report
to prep for tomorrow morning
this is how dedicated that guy is i put
my time in son it really does um the
ralph report
dot com is that where they can go to
join up yeah or to go to patreon.com
the ralph report take you directly to
where you need to go to hear me uh five
days a week in your ear holes
um that kevin smith club is another
place you could go to indeed i don't do
five days a week i mean what the [ __ ]
i got a hustle son i'm not like you i
don't have big ideas with a big universe
behind me
i'm just a just a squirrel looking for a
nut you and me both speaking of melissa
the noise she wrote this book with her
sister how sweet is that
that's adorable she's doing it like this
is like her first post super book the
powers haven't secret
melissa benoist and jessica benoist
with marico tamaki um you know like a
like
like a harry potter book kind of thing
kid you know why a action why a thank
you i was looking for the term without
being dismissive why a
she's so lovely um i was sad to see the
show end but also i understand like you
know she probably wants to go be a mom
for a while sure
and sometimes i think those shows are
best served with a
ending to them sometimes they can go in
a little bit too long no doubt no doubt
i was lucky to be involved for as long
as i was there man i
i ship mellywood very hard i love those
kids charms for you
um all right man [ __ ]
look at that some babylon action boom
in a long time brought to a screeching
halt by [ __ ] father time who's like
i'm old i have to work more after this
work is what i'm saying oh ring oh don't
go just
smoke pot on my balcony and just
looked down on the peons [ __ ]
ebenezer scrooge forgetting that when he
was a young man he was beloved and
[ __ ] you get figgy pudding and [ __ ]
like that now he's just
counting his [ __ ] coins telling bob
gretchen to [ __ ] off
not giving him a health plan and clearly
his kid could use it and [ __ ] like i am
bob cratchit i'm my own bob cratchit i
come in and i force myself to work in
ridiculous circumstances with your time
off you're scrooge and bob cratchit i am
a very strange guy i'm my own scrooge
that poor [ __ ]
befuddled big adoption of yours that's
[ __ ] tiny tim right there
broken poor [ __ ] thing reggie's with
the x wherever the kid goes the x goes
that's why the kid and the dog are with
the ex right now so i'm a free man
tonight which means i can pee in my
backyard
and then get back to work without the
dog being like wait you too this is mine
like [ __ ] my patch ownership bro that's
right great ralph garman ladies and
gentlemen uh you can find him over there
at the ralph report and stuff and we're
gonna figure out you heard the man
himself he's out there
beating the [ __ ] bushes to find
our new babylon home and once i will
maybe it's what's it called flappers
flippers
flappers is that what it was yes
flappers
flippers is where winter the dolphin
performed last before she died
flippers
she hated
she's like not all of us have flippers
you [ __ ] yeah um where is flappers
burbank
okay
where you sound crestfallen burbank's a
perfectly lovely town i love burbank i'm
just trying to get a picture in my head
i keep confusing it with that place
that's on lancashire what's up the ha ha
hut or whatever ho ho land ho ho ho ho
hotel
i don't i don't know
the chuckle palace
the chuckle hut
laughs a lot
um kids
regardless we're gonna figure out a date
get some live babylon going right here
in the hollywood area and double fist
some [ __ ] babble man yeah and then
we'll put it out to the world the way we
do commit to some uh new year's eve
action or you got something to do on new
year's eve no if we can find a venue
i'll i'll do new year's with you that's
our thing right how's the time to find a
venue i'll be honest with you i asked my
wife yesterday like the kid moved out
kid bought her own house and moved out
she lives in laurel canyon now what you
believe it my child rearing days are
over and thank god because that word
always [ __ ] bummed me out anyway but
she's on her own now she's grown ass
adult and stuff i was just saying yeah
we went shopping and [ __ ] was cute but
she got her own place point is empty
nester that's the point this place is
[ __ ] empty bro and byron and gayle
went to nevada for a spell so it's just
like me and [ __ ] jen so you know we
got that giant ass living room and [ __ ]
yeah british schwab yesterday i say
hey man like
like what if we like
since nobody's ever hear anymore what if
i took the upstairs and turned it into
like 100 a ticket
[ __ ] show place because we could fit
like 100 people up there
bro i got shut down so [ __ ] fast i
can only imagine it's your home i
honestly thought like she's been empty
nesting so hard i thought she might be
like oh my god i'll take 100 strangers
into the house absolutely
but 100 straight 100 it's your home it's
not a theater well you can't charge a
hundred bucks to [ __ ] go see me at a
fee like you're charging them 100 bucks
because it's just your house 100 seats
times 100 bucks do the math what is that
uh that is
ten thousand dollars i wouldn't even
have to leave my house bro
i could be doing a ten thousand dollar a
night show without leaving the comfort
of my own home all she would have to do
is tolerate 100 strangers
in her house that's all they can come up
the side steps if that's right and they
have your home address and they know
where you live that sounds fine that's a
great idea anybody can find me this is
the internet you can [ __ ] zoom
go on google and find my house and [ __ ]
because of google earth
the the guy i remember the day the
google earth
[ __ ] google maps guy drove past or
whatever the [ __ ] like i saw the vehicle
i was like i was [ __ ] up and for a
longest time
in front of my house across the street
from my house if you were doing that
street view right you could see me
sitting in the car wearing one of those
jerseys looking to the left
so i'm findable is my point
[ __ ] exploited i was like you know
the problem with doing a show remember
when we started our show at smodcast i
do
no booze at smart castle because we
didn't have a liquor license
for me there's booze in the back for me
but not for the audience there's always
boozer office um but if we did it at my
house
then i'm the bar as well bro and i don't
need no liquor license because they're
all guests and [ __ ] at my house and
mm-hmm you know we're charging we're
putting putting them drinks up at
premium prices and [ __ ] no minimums no
like to drink minimum [ __ ] you could buy
what you want
but
you know probably see like when you go
to a club oh my god
100 bucks ticket 100 seat house kev's
living room you're doing a goddamn show
we're doing babylon in the comfort of my
own home the neighbors are like shut the
[ __ ] up
so you want to turn your house into a
speakeasy basically
i mean what's left i've done a lot of
other things in my career that sounds
like it'd be fun for a while is that
illegal can i sell booze at my house no
what if i gave it away what if it was a
membership thing where everybody joined
for one night it was a blast yes make it
a swingers club and then everyone else
has to buy a membership
nobody no no none of your pissed games
at my [ __ ] house dude i i know you're
faster oh that's where you draw the line
that's the girl you're so fascinated
with this girl next time we do a live
show you're gonna be like who the [ __ ]
wants a face full of it
ah my bladder is full and you're gonna
find out so quickly that unless you're
like an attractive young woman nobody
wants a facebook you know me when i
gotta go i gotta go
this is the guy who's left the show like
left me on the stage to go [ __ ] piss
mercifully came back 10 minutes later
after he got his gigantic balls back in
his pants and [ __ ] but yeah
he'll he'll go
few like if you get him two drinks past
his [ __ ] minimum he'll definitely do
it what was her name sophia sophia
urista urista ralph urista
i could blow someone off the stage with
my uh with my psi
sophia urista the urine barista can fair
enough to say that i believe that's
that's her official moniker now yes
that's her media tag the dirtiest dad
joke of the night ladies and gentlemen
and with that we should bring it all to
an end
uh did you have a good time tonight
ladies and gentlemen i know i did yeah i
did as well if you did it was only
because that dude's sitting over there
which direction is it let me see this
way oh it's the other way yeah this is
only because this guy who i'm jerking
off to the side right there stand up put
your dick to the side of the screen
that's not your dick you fool you'd have
to stand up
okay i got the jerk and you on
and now put your wieners close to the
yeah all right let me get closer
yeah now that's
look at oh that's physical comedy right
there ladies and gentlemen look at that
that's why you watch this [ __ ] on the
internet that's right can't do that in a
live show
um give it up for the great ralph garman
ladies and gentlemen let's hear from my
bestest buddy and babel brother mr kevin
smith
and that is hollywood babylon for this
evening i'm kevin smith i'm ralph garman
uh tune in uh next uh
wait wait
you all right i'm gonna
babble the [ __ ] off
good night hollywood
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam soundbob get old up kevin smith